you
throw away those opening books
this is Fisher random time all righty
make sure you meet at that stream I was
gonna start the same way are we thinking
that we both want to help our bishops
out I don't want to kill my Queen
playing my knight here my bishop is very
upset would be very upset I like this as
a start because it's helpful for my rook
should this pawn make a capture and my
Knight once here has nice support
Knights directly behind pawns tend to be
a good thing how is that for a cool
general principle how's that okay so if
I'm not going to play my knight here
where is he going to go here
well placing a knight in front of a
central pawn isn't good if I play here
this weakens this square so I don't want
to do that so what am I getting at here
maybe my knight wants to pivot here and
here and we start to view this position
like it's a dragon it's actually a
dragon with a queen on a a variation all
right let's go here boom boom
what's he up to he's up to no good
probably let's get this in night here
bishop here castle as soon as I move
this guy could castle and actually I
move one I could have queenside castle
we both could queenside castle just pick
up the King and drop it on the rook and
voila you will have officially queenside
castle so let's get my knight here the
classic squares
dragon formation coming up a bishop here
he's doing a lot of nothing now he's
doing something let me get my queen here
so well I could do this right now but I
don't want to be in some pin so let me
just do this first just take that guy
let's just take him castle and now I'm
defending his pawn and I'm ready to push
so he shouldn't go too far away if my
opponent's gonna castle on this side of
the board with these light square
weaknesses my bishop could pounce on
those squares in fact if castling isn't
played now maybe I could stop that from
even occurring
let me however first throw a question to
this Knight and let my queen breathe a
little bit more by making that move this
is the direction I'd like to go and so
this is to very small reasons to make
such a move I have a space advantage
where my furthest advanced pawn is on
the Queen side I could do this and just
throw a quick punch at the Queen let's
do that Queens hit I'm not so quick to
give up my dark square Bishop so let's
do that
so if this night is to be kicked away it
would have to be with this pawn but that
would weaken another light-square it
starts to become a sensitive issue for
white use light squares hmm whoa now
that is crazy isn't it that the rooks
are connected but with all this
firepower still on the board I want to
now open the position now I was going to
do this move push and then push but this
night I'm a little bit fearful of him
getting to this square this isn't so
great
I'm not sure what I want to do but let
me just get my bishop to a better square
maybe there's opportunities to get on
this diagonal okay now I think it's time
to rumble here and by that I mean create
some paan exchanges somehow create some
pollen exchanges so that's what you
meant that's what you meant by Rumble
pretty upon exchanges okay hmm
eise --ax let's do it why not
we 5 noe 6 d 5 I may be Queen b6 pawn
push pawn push or just Queen b6 pawn
push I do give the knight this square
I'm not afraid of that should I be
should I be do I really need to no no no
no no I don't need this is this would be
I would chalk this up as overkill if I
really played a 5 to get in this advance
I could get it in right away and it's
perfect
there's big trouble here this night is
now pinned I feel like I could take a
couple times on this square play my
Queen here and then get a get a check in
or something now I think I want to do
this move yeah stop the knife from
jumping in the sea for if the knight is
maintained on c4 this rook he has some
trouble doesn't he he's pinned down to
the defense of c2 and now there's a
serious problem because I could crash
through on that square my computer just
slowed down there a little bit watch out
for the trickiness it's around every
corner now b3 right here where is that
me oh there's no need to be calculating
for me here
I'm hitting the Queen and I'm on the
rook
that'll be game over pretty sure all
right that night was stuck he was in a
pin a big pin
that King move that was I think asking
for some trouble with so many pieces
still on the board although it was it
was not open just yet you automatically
allow me to do what allow me to treat
Pinewood to have a new plan which is to
open lines crepe on exchanges
there's no good defense at that point
Queen and rook are head the game let's
go back if there's maybe one or two
things to maybe point out what would
they be well maybe this is just running
into trouble
where is he really going it's not it's
not completely clear where there is a
good home for the night because with
just these couple pawn moves I have not
created any hole in the position
this isn't maybe it isn't a good square
for this night because unless unless you
play E for and get this night to this
Square but I think this night would like
to play to D 2 and F 3 and kind of how I
ended up doing and maybe you should get
your C pun involved just as just as I
did just a suggestion I know it's kind
of like you're playing a mimicking game
but maybe maybe it does turn out to be
quite good these two pawn moves both of
us did this to help out our bishops but
until unless you could be sure c4 is a
nice home eventually I'm able to make a
useful move with tempo and that did come
about where I ended up playing b5 so C 4
is not a reliable home a3 is strictly
preventative I believe it's to keep out
the knight but I don't know that I'd
really want to go there unless you
really have this particular advance in
mind
so unless you are going to do something
like being for I think a three is not a
good option not a good idea
well maybe even right here like how
about how about you actually just go to
squares strike at my at a upon that's
more central the see pond beep-beep on
striking in a sea pond that's my other
suggestion instead of one step and go to
your queen is hit you're offering a dark
square Bishop exchange and the King
movies I'm pretty sure you simply can't
do that
although you couldn't castle because I
have this Knight takes pawn but maybe
before that even came about and by
before that I mean maybe right now
castle and if I am posting up on this
square then you play rook e1 just some
quick tips the against asking for
trouble really that King to d2 it's not
open just Yap up tough road ahead as
soon as the position does open up
alrighty good game
you